good evening everyone make a start I'll
start my welcoming everybody tonight to
the meeting of the East area planning
committee of Stratford district council
my name's Danny Kendall I'll be chairing
tonight's meeting in accordance with the
rules and procedure is set out in the
front of your agendas before we get
started I could remind members of the
public that make sure your mobile phones
are turned to silent and also to make
you aware of that we are recording
tonight's meeting so it'll be available
for you to review in the next day or two
on the council website should you wish
to do so our usual practice I could ask
people of top table here to introduce
themselves starting far-right please
Karen Tate I'm the team leader in my
role as an impartial adviser to the
committee I can clarify any planning
issues that arise doing so unbound by
the code of Professional Conduct of the
Royal Town Planning Institute planning
committee members are not bound by the
case officers recommendation or by all
advice jeff lahtie the planning team
matthew coin planning officer James
Watkins planet
thank you for right okay all that being
said if we go to our first item which is
apologies for absence we've got okay
disclosure of interests accounts Lipari
good evening chair I'd just like to
disclose interest as the ward member for
two applications this evening in respect
to Frissell Walton and King's Head hotel
and I shall be standing down from the
committee but we'll be speaking thank
you I've got yes counselor fielding
Thank You counsel Milt Thank You
chairman like everybody else here had a
communication regarding Frisco Wharton
from mid-shaft farm and a coin and I'll
just have myself item eight is in my
ward so I'll step down from the
committee and hopefully councillor Crump
can take over from me and then item five
and six are both in wells born East Ward
area I'm a member of the parish council
there but I on both of these
applications I hide stains so I can
continue and chair those two
applications there are no other
disclosure of interests moved to minutes
these minutes of the meeting held on the
7th of March and this is the meeting
cancer Trump chaired I've got a slight
amendment on them
76 disclosures of interests and it was
really nice that people thought I was a
warm member so I do find that quite nice
to receive that confident thank you fair
enough
can I change that aside from that you're
happy that we can sign those off thank
you
that's the countless like rumps like
those later if that's okay right before
we go to the first application you'll
notice that
item I believe it's just made sure I get
the right one it's a seven isn't it
items said them is the recommendations
can change to defer I'd like to move
that up so we deal with that one first
if you're all content we deal with that
one
so we'll start them with item seven
which is on page 57 this is application
reference 18 slash is zero zero two five
two / o UT into the land and building
career of japonica South and Road prize
Mastan the hell I'm planning application
construction of four dwelling houses
Stewart flighty over to you Thank You
chairman good evening ladies and
gentlemen um I have a playing
application here for outline Planning
Commission with all masses reserved for
a scheme for up to four dwelling houses
in the village of prized Marsden
you can see on slide one here the
location of the application is situated
here on the western edge of the pros
Marten village now here on slide number
two you can see that the application
site is located to the rear of japonica
cottage accessed off South and Road
my initial recommendation was one for
approval and to put some members an
issue has since come to lights this very
morning whereby you can see on the
application slide that there was a small
section of the application red line
sight that is within the prior two miles
and conservation area therefore being
that as it is there needs to be a
further round of stuttery consultation
which needs to be taken undertaken and
I'm therefore recommending to members
this evening that this application be
deferred until a future period of time I
don't know how much embellishment
Thank You members content with that yes
like yes capsule bars proposed deferral
cats Lipari seconded
all those in favor of deferral thank you
thank you therefore the results to defer
application reference 18 / 0 0 2 5 2 / o
UT Thank You Stuart okay back to the
running order as to build them since now
item 4 is found on page 9 of the agendas
application reference 18 / 0 0 1 8 4 / L
ful + 18 / 0 0 1 8 5 / L BC and it's for
Green Acres Farm badge is lame lower tie
so the description then is demolished
demolition and existing open carport
creation of wand Welling comprising new
building conversion of existing
outbuilding erection of replacement
carport and new garden store and other
associated works the second part is
exactly the same is just for the listed
building consent so presenting officers
Matthew coin over to you
Thank You chairman
the application is for applying position
listed building consent for a single
dwelling on land adjacent to Green Acres
in Leavitt I so the application is
indicated by the the black dot in the
center of the screen the application
site itself includes the residential
garden of Green Acres and an area of
approximately 20 by 40 meters the Green
Acres farmhouse is great too listed
building it's not within a conservation
area and there are a number of footpaths
that go adjacent to the soil into the
east into the north the redline site
plan includes the access from Badgers
Lane which is located to the south west
of this site the applicants also in
ownership will have access from the
lowest ISO Road from the north but
that's not covered as part of this
application that final point story was
covered in more detail in your committee
update sheet so the application site is
in Leavitt ISO which as you can see from
the aerial imagery is slightly separated
from middle and upper ties to advise an
area of undeveloped land between the two
this is the application site itself with
the farmhouse situated to the left of
the screen and the building the subject
to this application close to the center
this is the view taken from lowest ISO
Road towards the application site the
outbuilding just visible in the center
of the screen this slide shows the
access from Badgers Lane again the
outbuilding shown just between the two
buildings in the center of the screen
the farmhouse situated just to the left
the again the farmhouse shown on the
left-hand side of the screen with the
front and side elevations this is the
rear elevation of the farmhouse
and the carport which is subject to the
demolition just on the left-hand side
this is the rear elevation of the
existing outbuilding with the
development coming towards the front
this is a front elevation view of the
existing building with the farmhouse
situated to the left and the access from
lower register on the right-hand side
again the front elevation of the
outbuilding okay so the proposal is for
a single-story link building which you
can see just to the north of the
existing outbuilding and then a
single-story
extension sort of forming a H shaped
building includes a carport to the left
hand side of the outbuilding and a
garden store situated to the south east
corner of the site the proposals would
result in the conversion and extension
of the existing outbuilding to form a
three-bed Welling again in the same
shape of a H and these are the proposed
elevations with new windows and roof
lights on the front elevation a glazed
flat roof link extension between the
existing outbuilding and the new single
storey extension and then a hipped roof
a single-story extension to the rear a
detailed assessment is included in your
agenda starting on page 14 in summary
there's three key issues relating to the
principle of development heritage the
impact on the heritage assets and design
and in regard to these issues the full
application is recommended for refusal
for three reasons on page 23 and 24 of
your report and the list of building and
Senate is recommended for refusal for
one reason so on page 24 thank you Thank
You Matthew excellent right let's go to
our first speaker on this application
Simon and Miranda Forester please
well mr. Forester mr. forest I'm very
sorry I've looked at the wrong part of
the sheet apologies
supposed to go to the parish council
first I'm terribly sorry it's my fault
see I miss one meeting I forget the
complete system apologies for that
not at all don't worry you'll get the
time I'm very sorry
the correct person that should be
councillor Graham Colley please I said
parish council
I'm very sorry counselor so you have
three minutes remain seated for any
questions at the end and I'll give you a
warning ten seconds if that's okay ty
suppose council strongly supports this
planning application from a well
established law it's eyesore family who
have done much for the parish and a much
valued by it for example mr. Forester
was a parish councillor and was pivotal
in the work to resolve the 2007 flooding
issues in the village mrs. Forrester is
a founder and active participant in the
community orchard the applicants are now
retired and wish to continue to live in
the parish but have been unable to find
suitable smaller properties in the
titles they have therefore resolved to
convert the nether meant of new build an
existing building at grenadiers through
Gannicus to retirement dwelling the
building is an old farmyard and is
therefore a brownfield site and is the
reuse a varied Underland farm building
thus preserving the historic character
of the locality the Parish Council
asserts this is in compliance with
policy cs8 the proposed dwelling is
unique to the hamlet of lord I saw it is
on one level making it an ideal
retirement home for this and future
generations there are design features
address
sustainability policy cs2 the proposal
responds to the title housing needs
survey compliant with policy CS 19 and
like some early developments in law I
saw it will be a home for long-standing
local residents furthermore it is small
developments like this one that are
appropriate for the hamlet of law title
the parish council asserts that the
planning proposal complies with policy
s10 it will maintain and the hen answer
rural character contribute to the
vitality of title which a rural
community remote from urban centers and
develop within the confines of
brownfield site it is a conversion of a
building of local historic merit and the
policy indicates it to be for
residential use only the application is
supported by seven local had seven
residents local to Green Acres the one
object who was immediately placated
because there is a separate access to
the development for construction and
other traffic theis approach council
understands that the applicant has
responded positively to the design
concerns of the Planning Department
it also wishes to emphasize that it
considers the proposed extension not to
be conspicuous and that are not harmful
to the surrounding area including the
listed building this is supported by the
very detailed Heritage impact assessment
theis approach council asked therefore
that this Planning Committee approved
the application and thereby support
sensitive controlled and needed
development in our parish and in the
hamlet of law I saw in particular
perfect timing thank you very much any
questions from the committee
councillor Crump could you just hosing
me just elaborate on that please
okay you filled it meets that need they
the survey identified a need for
affordable homes retirement properties
this fulfills that need I can't give you
the statistics I'm afraid
lovely sentiment catch the punt see the
pictures that we've got up there on the
right hand side which [ __ ] of the
picture is think the [ __ ] on the
reverse and the that are not colored
blue are they did you have a question
related to the yes sir Perry
good evening counselor I just wonder
whether you can provide any information
as any work being done on the
neighborhood plan for the Tice's and at
what stage it's in development and it's
a regulation 14 there has been one draft
is being prepared and it's this sighting
has has this site been identified in
your initial like what does mound
suppose I know okay there are no further
questions
councillor Collier thank you very much
for your time q thank you all right
let's see if we get this one right this
time yes how can we help mr. Forester
please
or you still have your full three
minutes so if you'd arranged seated for
any questions at the end and I'll give
you a warning at the last ten seconds
whenever you want Thank You mr. chairman
we bought green acres farmhouse 24 years
ago it was so rundown a local builder
worked on it for a year before we could
move in and in the intervening years
we've restored the property brought up
our family and been immersed in the
title community we wish to remain in the
village and with these plans continue to
preserve the property I reached
retirement age four years ago and we
need to downsize for age and various
medical reasons we want a single-story
dwelling and one that is properly
insulated despite trying to find a
solution to our housing need for a
number of years there's nothing suitable
on the market this application meets our
need we believe we've done everything
required for a listed building by
commissioning five surveys including the
Heritage impact assessment conducted by
Professor Haman on behalf of
Warwickshire archaeology we've also used
an architect with detailed knowledge of
the property and who specializes in
listed buildings as evidenced by the
design and access statement in addition
the application complies with a number
of national and local policies it is for
us local people not a speculative profit
opportunity it involves reuse of an
existing outbuilding plus sympathetic
single-story new build on the site of a
previous building it is designed around
the criteria of lifetime homes to be
suitable for retirement it is in the two
to three bedroom category it's as eco
sustainable as we can make it and it's
within the physical confines of the
village and neighboring dwellings
councillors paragraph 62 of the latest
national planning policy framework says
within this context of meeting a local
housing need policies should identify
the size type and tenure of homes
required for different groups in the
community including but not
to older people and people wishing to
commission or build their own homes we
believe on the grounds of policy and in
the prevailing climate as expressed in
the NPP F and in initiatives announced
by Sajid Javid recently the presumption
is in favor of development where no harm
will be done this application would not
harm anyone or anything and it provides
the opportunity to conserve a listed
building that requires attention we ask
you to support it thank you thank you
very much any questions from the
committee please know that case mr.
Forester thank you very much thank you
okay and the ward member counts the
fielding please
welcome counselor thank you very much
can you give me a note one two and a
half minutes yes well that case you have
five minutes do you fellow counselors
Green Green acre farm house has been the
home for the foresters for the past 24
years and now their two children have
left home they're looking to downside as
mr. Forester Sidney's submission they've
been looking for a suitable property in
the area that is suitable to meet mr.
foresters long-term medical needs
but without luck as you've heard the
family have been involved in Tysoe
activities from the path from the parish
counselor to helped and helped around
the village Green Acres was a farm up
till the 1990s as with all farms there
were comprehensive set of farm buildings
some more prefab buildings have been
demolished before the forest has
purchased the property but the
Foundation's to several of the buildings
are still in situ the main access to the
farm is the track from Tysoe Road which
is a bus route and also dropping off
point
that right the building that building
with the brown done a bit Brown roof and
white is the existing shed they
consulted as we being told professor
Hammond to carry out an impact study he
considered the shed shelter shed which
is that which he indicates is that Brown
roof building had historical features
namely roof trust and stern wall at the
rear this building are shown on screen
is situated to the north side of the old
stockyard for the farm yard is
surrounded to the west by the farm house
which has been enlarged in 2002 and to
the east by to you bar if you can show
that one
keep going that that would
formerly a granary barn that was
enlarged in 2002 to the extent that is
shown on the screen on the south side
there's another large barn that was
converted into a residence 20 years ago
there is a narrow gap between this barn
and Green Acres farmyard just wide
enough for a large fan
it is a pinch point the proposal is to
provide mr. foster the residence that
will meet long-term medical needs but
make good use of the shelter however the
building is too narrow for a family two
and a half minutes 300 meters why thank
you thus by constructing a replacement
building on the footprint of the Oh the
sorry footprint of those foundations
still in place at the rear of the
shelter can you show that one please one
before that there you can see the one in
the middle of that Red Square and again
to join the two together by that nab
that comes out with the glass roof
decided building the the building I
consider meets the requirements of cs9
as being attractive sensitive to the
area distinctive connected connected to
the farm environment and sensitive to
the climate there is another pick
another one which is Google Earth which
shows where the site is in relation to
the there that shows the that white line
going across is basically the linear
area of the of that badge as close not
that one and that white dot is the
building that we are looking at CS 15 it
is a brief it is a under 50 under CS 50
into brownfield former agricultural yard
it's also developed developed a scale
appropriate to the meet immediate
surroundings it's lower than the listed
buildings and within the linear boundary
see us 20 this development will preserve
and enhance the character of the
location
under seus under cs10 a this which
basically I give my things right between
time it's a small scale for housing
employment or other forms of local
evidence on land within or adjacent to a
village ten seconds CSB small-scale
housing scheme CSC conversion to a
resident for use within the physical
confines of the village these buildings
just elapsed or perfect timing thank you
right any questions for the ward member
I have just one if that's okay I'm just
trying to clarify even maybe I'm not
keeping up properly so you're stating
that you believe these the application
site is a forum lead of a strongly
developed piece of land a piece of
brownfield site kept the brain the brain
Council bonds sorry go on council bonds
what you're saying is the attention
that's going to the barn
the new part is on an old footing Perry
Thank You chair I just would wonder
whether you'd like to comment on the
views in the report that identify the
design as being bulky it was highlighted
in the by the conservation office
that you know the the actual design they
wanted linear design was pre-application
advice sort just like to hear what you
your views in terms of the bulkiness of
the design they need to connect okay
there are no further questions for the
warden counsel fielding thank you very
much right points of clarification
committee councillor Perry Thank You
chair just wonder whether we can have
some clarity on the issue of brown field
development on this particular site as
being former farm areas yes thank you
chair this is an agricultural society
next agricultural site that in terms of
the MPP F policy in terms of the
council's policy wouldn't fall within a
brownfield site one thing I would also
like to raise at this point is the
reference to the building that was on
site indeed in previous times so far as
we're aware that building has long gone
using the argument it's a replacement as
far as we're aware that building that
original original building was probably
removed in the 70s and come sort of
building I think would be all the
applicants
thank you so that is that that's some
considerable time ago it should not be
taken as a president to a replacement
okay kept some funds if looking at the
picture that we have on the right hand
side which is the the extension and
which is the original building because
we've got two buildings there well I'm
trying to buy after that is our big the
extension which is inappropriate or
whatever the word is the conservation
our cadet use yes so the the the drawing
on the top left there that's the front
elevation that's all existing at the
moment obviously adding in new windows
change of roof covering the extension
Tory is to the the right-hand side of
this top right image so this is the
single-story link building and then this
is the new extension building and then
likewise the bit on the left-hand side
of this drawing and then this is the
rear elevation of the extension any
other points of clarification caps rode
on them so if the original building is
the one upon the left and then you've
got the link and then is this larger
area with a flat roof going to be behind
or alongside it wasn't I went to see it
yesterday yes so the the front image
that was on the top left under the
screen a moment ago is the front view
from a key from this side this is the
single-story link building and this is
the sort of single-story extension to
the rear so so the that would be the
front elevation view with the side to
side elevations here so that the new
part of the building would be on the
right-hand side of that drawing
Thanks okay so the link is all glass yes
it's also there isn't any it's glass
back in front so as it were I think on
this drawing on this side elevation
there'll be some sort of timber
screening but it's predominately made
out of glass the the roof as far as I'm
aware is covered with the glazed sori
flight or Lantern in that up and that is
probably your main objection because
there's not fitting you think the the
injection David designer to do with this
or the scale and the clarification
should we go to the debate harry i might
as well stop german this evening um
first of all i think you know i
understand i have every sympathy with
the applicant wanting to downsize to
something smaller
however i do have concerns obviously
they sought pre-application advice and
the conservation officer recommended in
terms of what sort of design would be
acceptable my problem is really with the
scale and the size of the proposed
scheme in front of us which is out of
character with the adjacent list of
building and whilst I do have sympathy
with the applicants wanting to remain in
the village and I can can understand
that from a planning reason and policy
perspective I have to go with the
officers recommendation anybody else
capsule bond because
the conservation architects always will
decide things like they are and you
can't actually say things like they are
just appear from what the parish council
said there was a poll that they wanted
old people's accommodation my concern if
there is a concern really is him isn't
that it season in the village sort of I
didn't think it was but could go either
way
cancer krump yeah we've had some before
are the last me till our previous one
where there was strong led was support
and we felt it was good but not quite
right and I think that falls into this
category as well I can sympathize with
the applicant and I can't see the need a
strong support from the parish council
and responding to the tosser local needs
over again it's it's pretty good
I believe the parish counselor said it
wasn't in the actual area of the
development and the emerging
neighborhood plan so again that's that's
that's against it so I think it needs to
go away and come back in a different
form and then it might come back with a
different result but um we'll go along
with the officers recommendation on this
one
I'm on I'm on I'm just a bit concerned
about their looking not I'm not in
keeping I mean again I I could see why
the need is to move to a smaller
property but it is design exploding
keeping with the new so I will go with
is recommend Asian fortunately but I say
it to come another design
yeah would be very very helpful
they're not working I think leave it
turned on and just speak up okay so what
I was saying was I'm in agreement with
my fellow councillors that we actually
need to look at perhaps this needs to be
tweaked slightly it's great that they're
trying to future-proof and age proof
accommodation that would be an asset to
tie so to have some accommodation that
suits that age group to keep valued
residents within a village I think is
key and important and for the
multi-generational living it's important
but I grew the mills that perhaps it's
something more linked to it's a look and
with scale that just needs tweaking in
principle it's a really good application
but it's just not quite right yet Thank
You counsel
well if there's nobody else wanted to
speak on this we I don't think it's been
proposed that we refuse it yet so I will
need a proposal councillor Crump you'd
propose the refuse orgy and councillor
the parrot to second in terms of bear
with me a second
that's okay right so sorry apologies
counselor croc to propose and counselor
parrots second about to just clarify
your reasons then for refusal because if
you flip through to page 23 there are a
number of reasons or three reasons to
refuse can I assume you don't think the
first reason the built up boundary is a
problem it's only the number two so it's
purely designer scale that we think in
these reviews don't sentences and it
would now read the proposal it's not
considered to be a conversion do you
want that reason these three reason one
relates to is that correct is that what
you're saying it is it's just all of
reason to and it's it's the design and
scale it's not so we can take reason one
out of our reason refusal you yep
happy okay so that would be taken out of
our reason for a few you can say you in
terms of the refusal putting together
you're happy that this will be part of
the belt of area or not only technique
parenting
what do you feel you know I think I'm
sabryna's because we've got it's a
substantial extension we're on about the
songs aren't we in this guy on
subservience so I think that probably is
still appropriate if it's going to come
back anyway I think we've given a clear
guide if it comes back why I think I
think applicants probably have heard
what we've said tonight they understand
very clearly the direction that we're
going in so in terms of I don't really
want to chop around with I agree with
you council mayor I don't really want to
chop around with this 23 and 24 officers
presented to the committee don't care
can I just comment
the first reason for refusal is a
principal reason for abuse or so that
would stand against the proposal per se
notwithstanding the design it is an in
principle this is not an appropriate
location for a new residential dwelling
because of its location what not in it's
not in this location does seem to me
that a lot of the discussion a sphere
from committee that in fact you feel
this is and that you feel that this site
is located outside the settlement
boundaries
so within lower tae-seok obviously part
of the disk part of the report relates
to whether this is within the settlement
or not I think no I think actually the
committee is that's not something we
want to discuss at this point because we
made other points along the way around
the development of the design and
whether we think it fits with the scale
we don't need to address I don't think
we need to address every point in the
reasons to refusal here we've had our
debate
discussion does anybody else feel a need
to add to this council pairing the other
thing I would say chair that you know
this was that sits out the side the bulk
built-up area Brown jury
it comes with community support which
should be considered again with a an
application that comes with a more
scaled down design but at the end of the
day it is this application this evening
before us has got a lot of community
support which then carries weight if I'm
right from a policy point of view whilst
being outside the built-up area boundary
if it carries the community support
which it clearly does in terms of parish
council support and ward members support
I'm concerned that if we if we keep that
in then it then it then it stops it
coming back because we're not saying I
don't personally I'm not saying no to it
I'm saying no to it because of its
design and scale and bulky feel which
was reflected by the conservation
officer but be guided by the officers on
try to that I think if we do take the
first sentence out that the planning
manager originally came up with I think
that answers caz the Perry's concerns
because we're saying it basically saw
its size scale subservience we're saying
we we were relatively happy on this
occasion because of the local support
that this is a site to be built upon
could be developed sorry business yeah
ten from all the words that so I think
that I'm happy for the three
recommendations to be in but the first
sentence don't - as far as furthermore
be taken out which I think there is okay
right I think could we ask you to feed
them because if we are going to be
changing this we're making a decision
about the built up area I think I can't
comment on the detailed application I'm
not for me
with the site and there a lot of issues
that been raised this evening around
design and everything two points about
the built up area boundary the district
councils positional the advice we would
give is that at this point in time the
district councillors defined a built-up
area boundary for theis so that excludes
lower theis so we know that Tysoe
neighborhood development plan was
produced as a draft last year and was
not progressed but may come forward this
year but we haven't seen that revised
draft that previous draft did include
lower theis so within the built-up area
boundary and our position has always
been that if it's the local community's
preference through the development that
the production of a neighborhood plan
that if that evidence is sufficient and
is supported by the community and passes
the the examination and eventual
referendum then the district answer
would be happy for lower ty so to be
within the daughter dairy boundary at
this point in time it isn't the district
hansol's boundary is to exclude though
it I so but if the application was to
come back in at some point in the future
and lower ty so was within the built-up
area boundary you know in a resubmitted
Tysoe neighborhood plan then i think
that that situation could change it's at
this point in time and so well I
wouldn't want if that if that first
recommendation was to stay in or that
reason for a fuse always the same was to
assume that that reason would
necessarily stand when the application
was resubmitted is because it could be
by then that lower ty so we would accept
his within the built-up area boundary
the second point I think I need to make
specifically is this reference to
what is proposed being to meet a local
need with all the evidence that supports
that I haven't seen any of that evidence
other than what has been said tonight
but the point would be if it is a house
at willing to meet and identified a
local housing need such a scheme would
not have to be within a built-up area
boundary anyway there was a specific
provision to meet local housing needs
outside of a built up area boundary
there are other site-specific matters
that would need to be addressed like
they have tonight should it come back in
but I make those two points specifically
right thank you
so yes the first reason would need to be
removed so that reason would start the
proposal is not considered to be a
conversion there is a reference to
policy CS 15 in reason one which would
also need to be moved and reason to the
there is an reference again to CS 15
which would need to be removed from that
reason so what you will be doing is
removing the reference to the principle
of development I'm quite happy to oppose
the new proposals okay I think probably
go stick with our original proposals and
second that's exactly what you proposed
be content with that council Crump as
well so we'll we will amend the we will
mend those reasons in the way that Karen
said so we'll be removing that first
sentence up to furthermore so we'll read
the proposal is considered to be sorry
is not committed to making a conversion
and that in point there will and remove
the reference to CS 15 and then in the
second point in point two we'd also
remove CS
fifteen as well everyone content they
all under you all understand good I'm
not sure I always do
lovely okay I think we're there then
okay we'll need to do this for both
obviously because we've got two
applications one solicit building
consent as well let's go to the first
one all those in favor of refusal with
the reasons stated thank you and I'll
need a proposer a seconder for the LBC
as well posed by councillor Barnes
second proconsular brain to refuse I
presume excellent on the same reasons
those in favor please show their for the
committee resolves to refuse
applications 18 / 0 0 1 8 4 / ful + 18 /
0 0 1 8 5 slots /abl bc right let's move
to our next application tonight
it's the Chairman if you were it does
appear that if you sort of talk from the
side it's better than talking that it
looks okay
apologies for that it seemed to have
sort out microphone issue we're gonna
have a go anyway see how it works
okie dokie right item five then on page
twenty seven this is application
reference seventeen / 0 - 8 8 7 / o UT
innisfree's Hale Walton it's the full
application for a permanent agricultural
worker that the workers dwelling and
representing officers Thank You mr.
chairman
outline planning permission is sought
for the erection of agricultural tied
dwelling located one-and-a-half one
point four miles to the southeast of
wells borne as shown by the black dot
the site which is an open field
currently would be accessed from Kyneton
Road along an existing private track
which is approximately 640 meters long
the access track serves a number of
other properties located along the track
here is a recent aerial view of the site
and the private track showing the
location of the new house in the red
rectangle at the end the site falls
within Feldon parkland special landscape
area both Hill and hanging break semi
natural woodland to the north of the
application sites are potential local
wildlife sites and are ancient woodland
the applicants have recently purchased
land at Friz Hill where they are hoping
to create a new farm and a base for
their business named Bruce Hall farm
there is an existing consent in place
for a grain store and a machinery fodder
store permission has recently been given
to use the machinery for the store for
livestock accommodation plus an
additional life livestock building so
there is permission for three
agricultural buildings in total none are
yet erected as mentioned earlier this
outline application is for the
development of an agricultural tied
dwelling for the applicants to reside in
close proximity to the approved farm
buildings to enable a full-time worker
to be read
at site all matters are reserved apart
from access there are no plans and no
elevation submitted with the application
the matters of appearance landscaping
layout and scale would be considered as
a later date should the outline
permission before coming forks rule
planning Land Management and Korean
countryside consultants of both provided
assessments of the proposals Foxy's are
recommended recommending that a planning
consent for a dwelling is not
justifiable in this circumstance whereas
Kernan's are satisfied that there will
be nee will be a need this slide shows
the view looking towards the plot in
front of the Sheep
the slide shows the view to the west
this this slide shows the view to the
east this slide shows the private
trackers it leads to the site and this
this slide shows a section of the track
further down towards the road again this
again this this slide shows another
section further down mr. chairman there
are two updates as detailed on the
update sheet relating to the payment of
sill at reserve at the reserve matter
stage and a further response received
from the agent covering matters that
could be included in his presentation
tonight his latest response is on the
website
mr. chairman the recommendations to
review refuses application for the
reasons detailed in the report Thank You
Alison okay go to our first speaker
there on this one is Andrew Lodge the
agent for the applicant please
welcome thank you for waiting you will
have three minutes to speak a
presentation as well a few photos of
dead sheep in this might be a little bit
distressing for some people yeah just
giving you a warning sir appropriate for
you other than that got three minutes if
you remain seated for any questions at
the end to you well firstly the largest
rests that the original consultants for
this application Kernan's stated there
was an essential need they base that
assessment on exactly the same numbers
of livestock as are now being assessed
by Fox rural that livestock number could
be up to two thousand two hundred head
of stock at any one time so we're not
talking small numbers I am a farmer but
I don't believe you have to be to know
that we're such numbers a year-round
presence is required
Fox rural are suggesting that the farmer
only needs to be on site for total of
six months of the year when there is
lambing and carving and it's a caravan
in any event conserve ice at other times
he is suggesting that the onset of
problems can be dealt with during normal
working hours and during daily checks I
strongly urge members to question this
approach a few issues to consider in the
week to pre impose carving and lambing
livestock are still heavily at risk with
problems such as prolapses twin lamb
disease magnesium deficiency early
births miss mothering and feed issues
and on-site presence minimises the risk
of loss checking once or twice per day
is no substitute for being there all the
time there are photos on there I
apologize to the little graphic but
there are problems that have occurred at
fris Hill since they've acquired it and
have led to loss that one is known as
grass taggers or magnesium deficiency
they lost 17 used last year to this the
other one is there it was twin lamb
disease they lost for you to that this
year the first 17 was post lambing and
the four years that were before learning
I'd argue if they were there this would
not happen
the second issue there are a number of
examples of holdings with far less
livestock numbers being committed
authorities you're being told these
aren't relevant as they're in different
locations I would question whether the
welfare of a circular cow in say East
Anglia is any different to any Stratford
District Council I frankly it isn't
a thirdly a large proportion of the cows
at Frist Hill will be carving outside
those carving periods in my experience
account can display signs for two week a
week before actually carving and during
that period you want to be there all the
time
fourthly I disagree with the six month
period but if you were taking what it
was would it really be reasonable to
expect a farm worker to live away from
their family and friends six months of
the year I'd like to finish with a final
thought
in 1988 the applicants father applied
for tied dwelling on their old farmstead
in Hampton Arden the farm had the same
levels of livestock as his proposed at
fris Hill this application was allowed
the difference was that this was for a
second Welling here you're being told
they can't have one times change but
Stockman ship largely hasn't please
support this application thank you thank
you any questions please yes counselor
Crump just some clear are you saying or
did you say something about an industry
standard for agricultural running for
the similar number of there are numerous
Appeal cases which would suggest that
holdings with far less livestock numbers
than this would be acceptable the normal
convention for assessing an application
for items which wire dwelling is to
assess the number of standard man days
that are associated with the life stop
element if the number of starkest under
man days is equal to one or more
full-time workers the convention would
suggest that there should be a dwelling
on-site and I would suggest you that the
vast majority if not in a late 90
percent of all applications would
support that view and that I believe is
what Kernan's the original consultants
assess is on yes Thank You councillor
Mills thanks Michelle good evening are
you saying that the where the is poor
sheep had died yeah
they have somebody been on site this
year in 2018 for the applicant started
lambing at Forest Hill they lost four
Lambs twin lambs disease this isn't
actually their own sheepish indicative
of God but that was a result of twin
lamb disease unfortunately for them on
that particular day we had a very heavy
snow and all the roads were closed so in
any event they couldn't get there
because the police had closed the roads
because of drifts and yesterday they
when they when they came the next day to
check them there was four four four she
passed away and what's the size of the
flock on this seven hundred ewes is
seven hundred years
can I ask you mentioned that they lost
seventeen use as well economically how
much would that have cost they died post
lambing the language will have survived
but they would have then needed to be
fed
oblivion selves so the lamb would
eventually survive they cost more to
rear but they use they're going to be
worth I would suggest 150 pounds per
head thank you
Thank You councillor bonds how big is
the hole in you you know holding number
that the a20 super cows and 80 use and
for extensive let me come in I'm just
trying to double check this sorry what
are you talking about the acreage of the
application site they rent another I
believe 70 or 80 acres within a stone's
throw under license and they retain land
and soon Arden
alba cropping and now currently in maybe
but where you want the house he's where
they're holding okay no farm buildings
anywhere else okay that's okay that's
five caps fielding basically based on
what counsel vans are just said is there
is no farmhouse per se for your
weathered where they personally live has
large holding their land holding has
been acquired by HS to a bypass and
it refers to M 40 I didn't think the
m-40 okay right there another further
questions it's large thank you very much
okay and now we go to our board member
kautz Lipari
welcome counselor sir you have five
minutes
Thank You chairman first of all I'd like
to set the scene with the following
historical background information
regarding this application the previous
owners of this 225 acre site benefited
from the facilities of Chris Hill
farmhouse with an agricultural tie based
on essential need however in March 2014
the owners gained planning permission to
convert the agricultural tide dwelling
back to full residential use an
application subsequently followed to
develop adjacent agricultural buildings
into an upmarket
residential barn complex which have all
been sold the 225 acres of land on its
own was constant consequently put up for
sale and acquired by the applicant with
no buildings or any form of
accommodation on-site last year after
investing pre-application advice with
SDC for the development of the new
farmstead which our planning department
advised that that time would be accepted
and welcomed in principle these are
special circumstances
thanks to hs2 and the introduction of a
service station of the m42 the applicant
has been forced to give up his farm
homestead in Warwick district following
a compulsory purchase order importantly
the applicant brings over 40 years
management of pedigree herds to our
district and can provide invaluable
mentoring to more important moral
agricultural college students the
current report commissioned by SDC
advises that there is essential need for
the agricultural tied dwelling as you
all know we often rely on reports from
Kernan's as a committee so why ignore
this one on this occasion it is my
understanding that wells Bourne and
Walton Parish Council who sadly are not
here this evening to speak base their
response on the Fox report and did not
have sight of the Colonel's report which
demonstrated the need for a grow tie
dwelling for the workers I'd like to ask
if you can ask the officer why the
Colonel's report was not have made
available to the parish council the
whole of the local farming community are
in support of this application and as
expert witnesses their views must be
taken into consideration
whilst I'm not a farmer even I can
appreciate the difference in the care
requirements between breeding prized
pedigree cattle valued at five thousand
pounds a head
compared to run-of-the-mill cattle of
1500 clearly the farmer needs far more
care and attention and particularly
throughout the carving period spread
throughout the year
there are also some inaccuracies in the
report respect of carving timings this
applicant carves in two blocks of two
months which does not mean four months
in total but actually eight months as
the pregnant cows need constant 24 hours
monitoring leading up to birth and after
carving which is understandable when
each calf can be worth up to five
thousand pounds each I also ask you to
question why a different location around
the country would have a different set
of circumstances in pedigree cattle
breeding than a farm in wells born I
therefore ask you to raise a question
highlighted to the officer highlighted
at the top of page 35 of the report
I'm also puzzled that the Fox report
refers to the lambing of sheep being
superfluous to the need of an
agricultural dwelling it is common
practice to carry out pre and post
lambing checks 24/7 in view of the onset
of hypothermia miss mothering prolapses
and twin lamb disease problems
suggesting that a student based in a
caravan can just check on the carving
cows all the lambing news and get the
farmer just to turn up at the crucial
moment in time and such valuable stock
is just ridiculous to protect the
welfare of all these specialist animals
a minimum of two agricultural workers
must be in attendance with the right
experience because it would be financial
madness to put the responsibility of
your prized herd of cattle or flock of
use into the hands of a student
attracting the right callable of
agricultural worker with the right
experience is not possible without being
able to offer them a proper dwelling
on-site there is just no way of being
able to tract and an experience like a
cultural worker to live in the caravan
for large parts of the year the impact
on his family social life is simply too
great these are serious special sir
stances and I therefore urge you to
apply both common sense and consistency
in your decision making process by
granting planning permission for this
application as you have done in the past
for much smaller sites and operations
and thereby helped to protect and
enhance a significant rural business in
the district if this application is
refused it will go forward to appeal and
based on numerous other decisions for
significant significant defined sites
will be allowed thank you for your
support in refers to in the report under
existing accommodation although there is
no accommodation on site of this new
farm
well spawn is any of one and a quarter
miles away there are plenty of houses to
rent or buy as you are in that industry
what is your feeling whilst there are
houses one and a half miles away
I think the applicants agent has already
explained when you have got carving cars
worth five thousand pounds and use
lambing you actually need to be checking
on them literally every half hour to an
hour through the night to drive to drive
one and a half miles and then come back
from wells born particularly if we've
had inclement weather like we have had
earlier this year when snow drifts you
couldn't you wouldn't even be able to
get down that Lane there is significant
essential need and the Colonel's report
has confirmed that willow at the tire to
a village Rita Carver because you
wouldn't see to do that I was going to
say the parish council are opposing this
application they say
there clearly haven't demonstrated a
need and the other thing was uh I'll ask
the questions of the offices later can I
would can I respond to that more of a
question for the parish council because
but they're not here unfortunately so
they can't really give you any advice on
this
I was attendant at the meeting that the
parish council spoke afraid you know you
what you don't represent the parish
council I'm sorry
Kelsey yes did you have a follow-up
question council bonds but it was it
related to ask if the the previous farm
house and buildings are are the
properties that are near that Drive and
it was the the parish councils
understanding thought they were still
still there and had removed the
agricultural need but they were not
aware that the any further questions for
the ward member please that case counts
of Harry thank you right points of
clarification councillor bonds over the
years where there is a need for
livestock attendance the NFU or abuse
Lea written in what I'm saying to you is
as a technical question can we put this
on a temporary basis like for a
three-year period can I could I propose
that in the respect of lead now it is an
outline application I appreciate that
but we have done that many years ago and
it was approved by the committee for a
three-year term I asked for the question
and I know it is more something you were
expecting I thought it might be the way
forward we asked you
yeah thank you the application is an
outline application for a built property
I'm pretty sure that councillor Barnes
is talking about the days of PPS seven
where in fact the the normal procedure
for a farm relocating or a new farm
setting up would be to allow a temporary
consent for a caravan mobile home
normally for three years to enable the
farm to establish itself to become
viable and at that point an application
would follow for a replace fault for a
house yes this is not what you have
before you what you have before you is
an application for a residential for an
outline consent for a built house yes
cancel break thank you German Chancellor
Perry highlighted special circumstances
quite strongly was running a special
circumstance admitted with the
application yes counselor fielding as a
precedent and as a question permission
was granted for a small bungalow or
small farmhouse in Radway on a farm
there that had a similar amount of stock
it went through last year the officers
granted it didn't come to committee
what's the difference between this and a
similar one in Radway I mean council
feel I should bring you back to the
point that we each each individual
applications be judged on its own merits
and of course that was completely
different application but it is a
precedent no it's not it's not a
president at all they're different
applications
yes councillor Crump
this is a point for clarification and
notify presidents regarding the
viability in terms of losses there was
plenty information submitted to
demonstrate that the farm as it has been
existing over the last four years is
financially viable cancel bonds
do we still have current advisers on
agricultural things yes we do actually
just follow up on that we had two
reports glad to ask the officer why we
went with one report and not the other
because obviously Kearns was
recommending there was an application
made in the summer last year which I
wasn't the case officer for which which
was submitted I suppose a different time
in the applicant circumstances where
they hadn't secured the other planning
permissions for the other bond and I
think they didn't have the same
landholding arrangements that they have
now
so Kernan's report that was commissioned
last year raised a number of concerns
about the I think the viability of the
land holding as they of the farming
practice as they saw it at that point in
time when I when we received this
current application the Kernan's report
would did not form part of the
application submission initially we
consulted Fox as we do generally try to
rotate between different consultants on
a just just we don't always use the same
consultants we have three different
agricultural consultants and we wrote
between them and then following the
Foxes report the agent submitted a
response to the Foxes report which
included the Kernan's report from last
year that response was then consulted
upon again with posh counsel and am I
correct in saying that the Kernan
reported them a report on both
applications no the Kernan's report was
dated last year I think that the
Kerner's report the issues that the
Kona's report raised have largely been
addressed and the outcome of the
Kernan's report was that there is if if
the scale of the operation is right is
roughly equivalent to what they had had
previously then there would be a
functional functional need so I'm gonna
effectively the first report the
Kernan's report found there was a need
for the dwelling for the second one has
shown that there is not a need for a
dwelling is that correct people report
so the original Kernan's report found
there was a need for Welling all year
round
but does the Colonel's report still form
any part of this application it does
because the so we can to the Fox report
and we okay and may see your content
that we could we can look at parts of
the Kernan report and it has the same
weight effectively just a couple of
points of clarification
first of all just out of observation if
Kernan's already knew the case would it
not have made more sense to stay with
that that company just just a point of
observation there but secondly how many
years five ability did you say it was I
couldn't hear if it's four or forty when
you mentioned it
four okay thank you but they've been
farming for 40 years is that what thank
you okay
any other points of clarification should
we go to the debate counselor brain the
farmer's son I know what it's like being
in the barn all night
carving cows and lambs not having a
house close by I think the circumstances
especially demonstrated there is a need
my problem is a special landscape area
looking at the map what's up there it's
in the open countryside it's over our
four mile from the road and that's a
problem I have cats the mills thanks mr.
chairman right
a very good friend of mine close friend
a sheep farmer lives in our village his
sheep are driving kinds and his cheap
are in Chad sont which is say a couple
of miles away and his cattle are in kind
some probably about half a mile away
he's doesn't live on sight
so I'm not an expert because I'm not a
sheep farmer I can only take this as an
instance and the fact that that sheep
had died from a disease I can't say I
don't understand why living on-site
would have prevented that disease I
don't think it would have done and that
could have been picked up earlier again
we've agreed with the knight brain that
is out in the middle of nowhere I'm a
bit torn on this one mr. chairman I'm at
the moment going to go with the office
recommendation thank you you do need to
be with livestock but it looks to me as
though if the position had been slightly
different not in open countryside would
have been better my concern is that
Kernan's have or happened or we don't
always agree weekends on their
assumption but as the last speaker said
magnesium deficiency is something that
you can spot so you can test for blood
tests and barrier things as I say down
by the river once either Carol I
couldn't catch you
I tried to do a woolly tree in the end
with a bit of string to carbon and we
caused the calf willow I can see the
concern I think a temporary permission
if they go in for a temporary permission
would be the best thing to do that's my
personal opinion so unfortunately I've
got to refuse this one as it is
yes cancer company reading the port but
the special landscape area and it is
quite nice on page 35 you said a
suitably where the condition would
secure the landscape enhancements I do
not consider that therefore there would
be any adverse impact caused by the
proposed development to the SLA so I've
you know that is quite clear I think
that the need has been demonstrated
and wouldn't this application on this
connection Caro Donnell I'm thinking
long the same lines as councillor Crump
representing a royal Ward and being keen
to support the rural economy I think
it's a responsible not to have people
living in appropriate accommodation on
site 24/7 when there's livestock
involved farming is not a nine-to-five
job it's a lifestyle and whether it's
your prize you know heritage fruit or
your run of the mill livestock they each
deserved you know you have to have
people on site and with the beasts needs
we've just heard they'd never have got
close to that living among the halfway
and Wiles born so I'm going to much to
go against office recommendation will be
supporting Thank You Council fielding
and if they're putting up the new
buildings which I believe what they've
got permission for am i right they do
need to have accommodation and because
the building has got to be inspect if
they've got livestock in the buildings
there are always problems in the
buildings as well as outside and I'll go
along with councillor crampon right I'll
add my thoughts I think I agree totally
with councillor Trump I think that need
has been demonstrated quite clearly and
seeing as we can look at both of the
report that looking at whether this is a
needed dwelling I'm I think that I would
choose to go along with what current
says rather whatfox so I think there is
a demonstrated need I think you're quite
right in terms of the landscaping I
think we can make this blend in quite
well it doesn't have to stay stick out
too badly I'm happy I also go against
the officers recommendation on this
occasion with no one's proposed this yet
but hey we want to propose a can't so
Donal propose that we grant for both yes
thank you
seconded please by councillor fielding
we'll need to discuss first of all
recommendation is on page 37 thank you
yes so our reasons and for granting
would have to change presumably to the
fact that we believe that there is a
demonstrated need so would we reword in
this to satisfy that there is a
functional need for the citing satisfied
that that need has been demonstrated
through parish reports so that will be
reasons yes and then we've got a set of
draft conditions here that we've put in
place submission of reserved matters
type and timescales proof plans external
materials landscaping soft landscaping
levels bins water birds electric vehicle
charging points scheme foul service
water disposal maximum Ridge height six
point five meters seven meters should
that be seven meters occupation dwelling
of agricultural worker removal PD rights
and widening of access and there's a bit
of displays so those would be our
conditions are you content for those
will be the conditions applied to the
application I'm just checking before we
go to the vote though yes so count so
who Donal your content for those
conditions and councillor feeling you
would be too right so we'll put those
down without draft conditions though
should we go to the vote all those in
favor of granting the application please
show thank you
therefore the committee resolves to
grant application reference 17 slashes 0
to 8 8 7 / o UT for the reasons stated
our next item is item 6 and found on
page 41 okay
the application reference is there so 17
/ 0 2 3 3 1 / ful 17 / 0 2 3 3 2 / LBC
this
for the king's head Hotel chocolate road
wells born and is for the
internal/external alterations Excel to
include the removal of a
twentieth-century porch and a creation
of a new pedestrian route path from car
parks the front entrance presenting
officer James Hodgkins James Thank You
chair
so as denoted by the black dots the
application site is located within the
village of Wiles borne the King's Head
is a grade 2 listed building there's
also located within the wilds borne
conservation area the site forms part of
a cluster of listed buildings and is
adjacent st. Peter's Church as outlined
here the application seeks full planning
permission unlisted building consent the
external and internal alteration of the
building and associated landscaping
works the headline works include the
removal of the port on the Warwick Road
elevation which is this one here a new
lighting scheme the creation of a new
pathway from the carpark to the Church
Street entrance which is this walk side
here and internal refurbishment largely
focus on the reintroduction of the
historic bar and this is the aerial
photography just the red line denoting
the application site you have the chaco
slash Warrick Road when you're here to
the north and this is the Church Street
entrance so these the the existing
elevations if I skip on to the proposed
I'd point out some of these changes so
the lighting scheme just going around
here the small smaller down lights here
and this is the porch that's proposed to
be a sort of a skip back there there's
slight changes here to this to this
porch porch way this is the existing
site plan and again the proposed just
outlined some of the changes and I'll
just highlight them again so there's
some fencing here and create a negated
access this is the the pathway that
comes from the carpark and through to
this entrance on this side the existing
internal layouts and the proposed I
appreciate that the the detailing is
quite small there evolve see it's a
listed building consent applications
there's quite a large amount of detail
near on the plans and these are just
some of the some of the internal changes
so the the bar 200 details and yeah just
just some photos for the context this is
the Talcott road warrant Road elevation
weather changes to the port are being
made and this with you into the garden
this is the other side of the building
on the church streets elevation this is
the current carpark so the pathway would
go in behind these and the Rose Arbour
and this is the current situation to the
carpark from the garden just the
internal arrangements where the bar is
going to be really focus to be
introduced and the church is the setting
this is just some basic details
regarding some of the landscaping
elements so this is the the timber
archway that would form the the
connection between the carpark and the
garden and these the lighting details
and the palace palisade fence in details
and an update has been provided which
outlines further consultation comments
and highlights changes to the conditions
the recommendation is to ground subject
the conditions outlined on page 53 of
the agenda and as per the update thank
you Jeff thank you James
right okay get our first speaker Richard
Colley please on behalf of objectives
welcome thank you for waiting around
thank you so you have three minutes if
you remain seated for any questions at
the end and I'll give you a warning it
last 10 seconds if that's okay of to you
I just wanted to ask the members to
consider three questions to ask so these
are really just memoirs and I've put
three photographs in the first one is
the picture from the Keeks head from the
shark Hood Road my understanding is that
in the Heritage stage and any heritage
statement needs to be based upon of maps
and photographs in generally are places
which are built on main roads
they are there for food the drinks and
for in before motive a motor-car days
horses and you can see this is the front
entrance in the 1920s on the right
you've got stables for horses and also
three signs we go to the next slide this
is church street in 1910 you can see
there's no footfall there there's no pub
signs it was always a cul-de-sac and
I've gone back to 1733 enclosure plan it
was a dead end and it wasn't marked as a
pub in 1733 in fact there was a quiet
residential entrance so the first
question that artists members to ask is
why does the applicant assert in its
application that Amin would ever have a
front entrance on anything other than a
main road have a second one which I
don't have a slide for question there
seems to be continuous ambiguity as to
what the primary entrance is the case
officer stages on page 52 paragraph 2
following the full mentioned revision
the primary entrance at Podesta axis
from Rock Road has been retained but if
you look through the elevation documents
we saw one earlier brutalized elevation
Oh H C which was done in March this year
still shows the childhood roadside as
being the front and the Church Street
entrant has been the back so the plans
and the words in the application don't
stack up
and yet the application and all the
merited with it states creation of new
pedestrian route path from car park to
front entrance so I think to me a
primary entrance must be the number one
entrance to any building so there needs
to be clarity as to whether it's of
trial Cairo where traditionally would
have been or in Church Street there
can't be more than one primary entrance
because it's where most people will come
in and out of the building so can the
members sleep
and the third slide please
this is the existing entrance from the
garden into the side porch on Church
Street you can see is gated it does
metal high roads and I want to
understand why when the highways
authorities saying that there's new
entrance is going to public highway the
existing entrance isn't being retained
thank you thank you any questions please
if cancer company mr. Connelly one of
the 14 objectors yes I am I don't have
no objection to any internal elevations
my objection is a volt fast about what
as being the traditional front entrance
to a quiet residential street and I've
believe obviously they can we've heard
final comments from the County Council
on highways and they've still got some
objection
I think the highway I don't know where
you've actually seen I've seen it they
still have yet because if you look at
the final plan that there is an entrance
it's been moved to vegetation on the
right yep so there is no pavement there
so the deaf students would be coming
from a car park where you're currently
using for car park spaces around through
to a residential quiet
conservation area and being redirected
into the building from a public highway
any other questions
Mr Colley thank you very much thank you
okay
Mr Davy applicants agent
welcome to Davi thank you for waiting
around so you also have three minutes if
you'd remain seated for any questions at
the end over to you good evening my name
is Nick Davey and I'm representing the
owner and the operator of the the king's
head as everyone knows the king's head
is an important community heritage and
economic asset and it makes a
significant contribution to the
character of world's born and most of
the villagers will at one time or other
Vita nor trunking or perhaps worked in
the public house and the company does
take it social and civic amenity
responsibilities very seriously and it
proposes to make a significant
investment in both the building and the
business in order to assure that it
continues to contribute to village life
for many years to come
it wants to refurbish the building with
an historic and long-forgotten bar being
brought back in to use a modern
unsympathetic edition will be removed
and the grounds will be enhanced and
your officers who have provided
invaluable input into the scheme over
the last nine months confirmed the
internal alterations will enhance a
special interest of the building that
the external alterations which we've
just been talking about will improve the
appearance and character and that they
will also and the proposed landscaping
will also improve the character of the
site and its associated setting so the
proposal has been assessed is enhancing
the listed building and the conservation
area and hopefully that carries
significant weight in your decision and
the application has generated
considerable interest and while the
improvements to the building are
generally welcomed concerns have been
raised relating to parking provision and
additional activity in Church Street on
the first point there's no objection
from the highway authority to the level
of parking which complies with relevant
standards and importantly the company
would not be proposing to make it exist
a significant investment in this site if
it considered there would be there was
insufficient parking as that would
restrict its business on the second
point that very little change is being
opposed to any of the vehicle or
pedestrian arrangements to enter the
site of the building they're all the
same on the charcoal road frontage and
the building does have three entrances -
sorry - on the chocolate road frontage
and one for customers on the King's Head
frontage and we're not changing any of
those customers can come and go freely
by any of those entrances now and
they'll be able to do the same after the
scheme the only thing we would like to
do is improve the current route and
there is an existing grooves between the
car park and the Church Street entrance
it's currently a set of steps along that
road and to make it easier for customers
to get from one thing other we'd like to
create a level road which means we need
to move it slightly and put a gate in
the boundary wall that's the extent of
the change that's not really going to
affect how customers will enter and
access the building they'll Park in the
carpark and most of them I think most
airplanes are the the building so in
summary the company would like to make
the significant investment in this
building maintain its community use and
the contribution it makes to the
character of the village thank you any
questions please mr. Davy thank you very
much
Thank You members we go back to our ward
member again capsule Ari
welcome back over to you I don't need
all of my five minutes I think on this
application first of all I'd like to
emphasize I'm fully in support of all
the internal refurbishment plans which
are welcomed and hopefully would drive
increased custom to the king's head I do
have concerns about the reduction of
on-site parking
and obviously the relocation of the
front entrance to the rear of the
property and consequently the impact
that will have on residents in Church
Street from a parking and environmental
perspective there are many activities
that happen in the church hall and at
the church during the busy times of of
the pub opening hours and it is normal
that people want to drive as close as
they can to what is named as the front
entrance which would mean coming down
into Church Street I really do feel that
the public access to the Kings ed must
be from the child cut road and remain
that front entrance it is it it's always
being the front entrance and I do feel
from a material planning decision its
effect it would affect on the
development and character of the
neighborhood by moving the front
entrance to the quiet residential street
in Church Street Church Street is a
residential street and it is
particularly busy at weekends and I
ventured I've mentioned also before the
the various community events that take
place street parties etc and I do feel
that driving customers to go down into
Church Street Park because obviously
there is a reduction in the car park
will have an impact there's also a
cumulative impact on parking provision
in the neighboring streets as you all
aware we approved planning permission
consent for change of use for a
restaurant in in the warrant
at the end of the day welcome internal
refurbishments but I do feel the front
entrance for heritage reasons needs to
remain the front entrance and therefore
there is no need to bring a pathway from
the carpark round to the back and create
that the front entrance because it is
going to inevitably increase traffic
flow down into Church Street thank you
any questions for the ward member
councillor fielding disabled car parking
is round the front it's going to be a
long way from the entrance so people are
going to disabled people are going to
have to park in Church Street in order
to so they don't have to walk as far as
required nothing brings clarification
okay any other questions yes
councillor para just thinking about the
congestion in Church Street and having
gone to a number of classes in the
village hall they're not sure the name
of it
when is that artists busiest you know
does it tend to peak at the same time as
the certainly as my knowledge as the war
as the war member there are many things
like swimming classes in the evening I
believe Weight Watchers and slimming
world both hold their classes in the
church hall so and that's during the
week and then obviously you've got all
the other events the church hall is
regularly hard out for private use there
is a park adjacent to the church hall
but a number of the properties in Church
Street because of the character and
historic nature of the street it has to
be on on on Road parking there isn't
that they did that the houses don't have
or only very few have actually on-site
parking so it's just going to it is
going to cause pressure all we're saying
is
keep the front entrance where it is it's
just a design issues but do welcome the
internal changes speed of traffic in
Church Street so if people are actually
access indirect the carriageway up to it
from the from the public house how fast
just traffic go down traffic down in
Church Street it it because it's a dead
end it traffic moves fairly slowly to
try and see if they can find a parking
space yes the the church art has a very
significant War Memorial which then
links into the grounds and to public
open space so yes Church Street is used
by walkers dog walkers no it is any
other questions for the ward member
that's thank you very much counselor
okay points clarification yes counselor
just a quick one really the candy
council appears highways are opposed in
this application over the years every
time they've done that and it went to
appeal and we were told that we were
liable from ASA that's correct if there
was an accident
well I think I've advised to Committee
on this point before but be very wary
about giving against a County objection
because base is the liability on any
accident transfers to the District
Council okay
it went to appeal and the inspectors
said that well basically it's case law
that basically says that the council
generally when it comes to planning
permissions doesn't know a duty of care
but because this is Astrakhan salty and
they've object
on situations like highways they do over
duty of care well may owe a duty of care
that's why I'm saying be very wary about
doing against a County obligation yeah I
mean we've got a candy council approval
for the car parking but an injection for
the footbath f-series should we take
though that was going to be my question
I'll just have the answer any other
points of clarification councillor
fielding which part of the highways
they've already got access and egress
anyway from the road yeah it's just the
piece the County highways are still
objecting to that's fine I'll just give
a bit of a summary you can still access
the public house from all access points
so you can still access from the toolkit
Warroad elevation side and you can still
access as is today you can access the
church street side the the difference is
is there's a pathway from the car park
to save pedestrians walking through
through the archway here and then into
this entrance or this entrance and
instead having a pathway to this
entrance on the church street side the
objection to County highways there was
initial concerns regarding in-and-out
access that's been resolved there are
also concerns about the fence level here
but that's been set back so you can
still access here but the objection from
County highways is the fact that
effectively pedestrians have to cross
the highway from my own cursor here to
my cursor here that's where the
objection remains and so the objection
really is to I suppose the the physical
movement from this point to that point
if for instance the pathway wasn't
created you could still access and exit
and enter the building from this
elevation from Church Street that that
is an existing arrangement
council brain any other points
clarification should go to the debate
counts the bounds oh sorry we've just
looked at the site plan all the photos
oh the one where you're fiddling around
with your cursor you have to tell me
when to stop
yes so so there there has been some
ambiguity over what is the front the
main entrance
I appreciate it's been termed the main
entrance on the site here obviously this
entrance also still exists that is the
terminology that's been used but both
entrances are are present well well in
terms it depends would be preference i I
mean if you're walking from here I would
suggest that I personally would walk
into this entrance if I lived here I
would suggest I'd go to that entrance if
I was parked there I would probably take
the path in terms of what's listed on
the plans that one has the title of main
entrance the new one in Church Street
that's correct right
these still points of clarification so
my assumption of what you you meant
about the disabled parking as if you're
parked in the disabled base here you
would have to go round this way to get
round to here to this entrance yeah well
that's not necessarily correct because
the entrance still remains here and here
this is a pathway if you go if I go to
my photograph you can't fully see that
but under you as the car park ends you
get a pathway and that could take you
into that door here and if you
the front so that that effectively is
opposite the cardi the disabled base so
you can still get in through this
entrance if if you were parked in the
disabled Bay's again I suppose that
would be a preference
I don't assume that you would go all the
way around but that's an assumption is
this a follow-up point the archway of
the the elevation on the warwick road
side do you mean where the cart started
this okay apologies so this this isn't
proposed to change that is that is being
retained at present if you park up here
you'd have to walk through this way to
get to but yes so traffic goes so
traffic and go both this way and this
way it is a dual dual multi multi
directional arrangement on the basis of
highways recommendation to not go one
way yes mr. chairman thank you very much
confused of kinds in here I have to say
the main entrance to me is the entrance
on the on the child cut road and with we
shopping and I've lived in the air of 34
years to me that's the main entrance now
you're saying the main entrance is the
entrance on Church Road it is the main
entrance is on chocolate Road yeah I
mean if that's what it is at MoMA the
the point in which the objects are made
in terms of the retention of the main
entrance at present I would we would
argue that at present you would use this
principally because of the path
arrangement and and that's why that's
mentioned there the in terms of the
plans is proposed that this is a new
front end the word front has been used
and that's where the confusion has
arised there isn't
the word front is used because to which
entrance this is where the the objector
has raised his point so the word front
is used in reference to this elevation
but in terms of discussions with the
conservation officer there wasn't a
conclusion as to whether this
historically would have been the front
and that the rear or this the rear and
that the front she said it's quite
possible it's not definitive but quite
possible that you would have had a front
entrance here in relationship to the the
church and the village but equally
speaking it's quite possible to have the
entrance on the highway so I appreciate
there is ambiguity the the point I'll
make is all entrances exist and are
being retained the wording suggests that
this is the front entrance and obviously
that and the reason being is because you
have the link from the carpark the
Highways object to the okay countless
capsule by which we go to the debate
please well yes I would live proposed
refused along highway vans I don't think
I could sleep at night when I'm sort of
said oh well helplessness it is alright
and highway said it wasn't it needs
addressing now I'm quite happy to
propose refusal on the grounds put
forward by hello Thank You council brain
I'm gonna be a bit different actually I
think it would be nice to support it I
think it's with us prematurely I think
we should have waited for the answer
from the highways and had a clearer
picture what we were voted on tonight as
a recommendation I think it should be
deferred until we've got the response
from the highways the other role turned
in his refusal which I wouldn't want to
go with there's much of a difference in
this case really council military
chairman yeah I can't go along with this
so in the impacts on the residents of
Church Street
enormous this has changed the main
entrance seems to be crater to me just
in my mind there's no need to change
this entrance and the main engines in
the back where it says impact on
settlement Church Road which is
essentially a quiet street so I'll go
along with you opposite recommendation
was Jim okay right instructing to be
done double Thank You chair um I mean
highways very rarely object for mics for
its the sitar so we must take their
recommendation really seriously I agree
with and councillor Perry that the
internal changes seem to very positive
but you know using Church Street myself
it's really very busy and congested so I
can't see how that could possibly work
it just needs nonsensical when you've
got such a good entrance on the
chocolate Road so I can't go along with
the recommendation right councilor
dollar I take it you're seconding Lee so
I was just trying to tell me what you
would say I'm sorry yes okay right yes
I've just taken the proposal and second
to first this was proposed for us I'm
happy to go tools in a second that's
just if and Karen or we'll come back to
it thank you point of clarification this
is an application for a number of works
including internal works to the building
the issue in relation to the entrance on
Church Street is one element of the
proposal in refusing if you move to a
refusal obviously you're refusing the
entire application it does seem to me
that in fact your concerns are relating
to this entrance point and the pathway
to it through the car park would you we
have the applicants agent in the in the
audience one option would be to look to
the application you've given a very
clear signal to thee to the agent
I support the issue with and to instruct
James to go back and have further
discussions to remove or to come forward
with an alternative which is likely to
be more acceptable to you if the only
reason put forward very abusing these
highways the rest of it will go through
only I think I'm not sure I understand
that we are waiting for any further
update from Warwickshire we've got the
decision they're objecting to it I don't
see how we can defer it when we when
we've got a very clear statement from
highways they're not happy with this now
we could change the application but I
think that's a new application kinesin
amendment it's not possible condition it
for the question I think on the first
application we have the principle it was
good not right come back with a new one
and I think this is the same applies
again I'm very concerned about the
highways objection
again from a big multinational applicant
night which wasn't bought there's PLC he
would have thought they would have been
able to work with the County Council to
try and can't the scheme to remove the
application so I agree I think the
application is premature and if it had
have waited a bit longer got the final
information back from the County Council
and work with them we could have had an
application that would have we would
have been happy with him been out to
pass but at the moment I'm not happy and
I think we should refuse it right it's
going to calculation from Mesa I've got
a proposal a seconder for refusing had I
stand with the counts of brains
proposal to defer your content okay I'm
just checking so we can go to counseling
okay let's do that then
right so the reasons I think we've
stated quite clearly for the reasons
were that you proposed refusal all those
in favor of but I check with the reasons
for refusal due to highway safety and
impact upon neighboring amenity of that
of that area is that is that correct or
is it just one or the other both yes
so what to do with that entrance in
highways okay so we can we take these
together as one vote so this is for both
the full application and a list of
building a consent
so we don't have to deal with at all
okay all those in favor of refusal
please show thank you and those against
and abstentions thank you therefore the
committee results to refuse application
reference 17 / 0 2 3 3 1 / ful and the
other one falls away because the first
one so item listed building consent
apparently doesn't it doesn't apply and
how come tomato because
only resolved to refuse with buildings
17 / 0 2 3 3 2 / lbc on the fat on the
grounds of the first the principal beam
but you also need to vote on the listed
building consent as well do I presume
that your reasons would be the same in
terms of because the highways are
objecting can I have a proposal for that
please
councillor Donald to propose capsular
battles a second all those in favor of
refusing the listed building consent
please show thank you and those against
or abstentions and then we will have a
two minute break thank you everybody
therefore the committee resolves to
refuse 17 splashes there are 2 3 3 2 /
LBC
right okay we're back then this is my
ward so I'll hand over to catch the
Barnes you ready right we'll move on to
item item the agenda which is
application 1800 to some not a few units
eight was born distribution Firefox Lee
Road was born and it's a change the
views from b8 storage to be to
specialist production facility cladding
of an existing warehouse eruption of
mezzanine floor inside unit and the
construction of a new car parking of a
new car parking with associated external
or just whatever the word listen with
associated external landscaping and
we'll move over to Eddie and I'm sure
will explain where there's a word
missing there as well
thanks Thank You chair the site is
located on the southeast and edge of the
village of wells born within the
existing industrial assay
adjacent to wells born airfield as
denoted here by the black dot the Union
subject to this application is setback
some distance from the lovely Loxley row
to the east and is surrounded on three
sides by existing industrial warehouse
units the site is outline here in red
and shown as a unit eight this is an
aerial view of the application site
showing the surrounding built form and
adjacent uses this slide shows the
proposed layout of the site with the new
parking area in around here and the
proposed mezzanine floor within existing
building would be
area these are the proposed elevations
for the Union which would be clad in a
mixture of dark and light great colors
to match the recently recent upgrades of
other units across the Industrial Estate
and finally these are two photos of the
existing units updates include an
updated representation from County
highways removing their objection and
one additional condition which they have
proposed chairman the recommendation is
to grant permission subjects the
conditions in nature data
outlined on page 68 and 69 of the agenda
and the one condition on the update
sheet will also just confirm that this
application is coming full committee
based on scale alone thank you very much
I'm kidding
we'll move on to our first speaker which
is cancer Kendall suppose I've got
absolutely no objection to this it's a
great development is good for Wells born
no one objects only ever any points of
clarification no just make sure they did
it properly and I propose that we go to
the recommendation proposal
committee resolves to grant application
1800
thank you
pleasure to be back I did some nine it's
our last one of the evening this is
application reference 17 / 0 1 8 3 0 /
very and it's the elms plough Lane
bishops itching to miss is a variation
of conditional - I'm not going to read
all that out of that think Eddy perhaps
I could go up to you your posture
Thank You chair the application is to
extend the life of the existing solar
farm from 25 years up to a maximum of 40
years the site is located on the eastern
edge of the village village of Bishop
teaching - and is accessed from plough
Lane to the north the entrance to the
site is done it denoted by the black dot
here in the center of the screen there
are a number of public footpaths in the
vicinity of the application site as
denoted here by the green dotted and
solid lines and also you can see the
development bill develop within Bishop's
each engine to the east the site area
extends to approximately 29 hectares and
as well as the panels the site also
includes a transfer station a collecting
station to energy storage containers as
well as security cameras and fencing
this is an aerial view of the
application site showing the solar farm
as it is constructed today finally this
photo gives a general view of some of
the panels and on-site buildings as if
you'd just off plough Lane chairman
there are no updates to report chairman
lee akeem recommendation is to approve
the variation subjects the condition and
notes on pages 88 and 89 of the agenda
to confirm this application is before
members because of the ownership of the
site is by one of the council employees
thank you thank you there are no
speakers any points of clarification
debate you propose do we go to
recomendation okay and seconded council
Mills just beat you to it or not all
those in favor please show
you have all the committee resolves to
grant application 1701 eight-30 slash
bearing concludes business of the
evening thank you very much